This is just too perfect.
Donald Trump's beleaguered impeachment lawyers
have misspelled United States in one of the
early documents they put together for the
impeachment defense of Donald Trump.
Instead of saying the United States, they
wrote the Unites States unite unites Unites
States.
These were the lawyers.
This is so insane.
These were the lawyers hired Monday, I guess,
after Trump's original lawyers quit on Sunday
night.
They this was a document, a fourteen page
legal brief written to members of the United
States Senate, except instead it was written
to members of the United States Senate.
It also I mean, listen, it's I remember when
I can't believe this is the timeline we're
in.
But remember when Rudy Giuliani farted?
I mean, I don't know what I could use a more.
I could use another term, but when Rudy Giuliani
farted three or four times during one of those
bogus voter fraud hearings and of course,
the fart was covered extensively, but it was
not just the style that was weird about that
event with Rudy Giuliani regularly farting
while speaking.
It was also the substance, the substance of
what Rudy said, as I previously reported to
you, was just as disgusting.
And in this case, it's not just that the 14
page legal brief refers to the United States
as the United States.
It's also that it makes absurd legal arguments.
The 14 page document argues that impeaching
a former president is unconstitutional.
Now, what you have to there's there's so many
reasons this is ridiculous.
First of all, senators don't decide about
the constitutionality of things in the United
States.
This is a political trial, OK?
And although arguably too many senators are
former lawyers, and I've I've advocated for
more diversity in the types of folks who are
U.S. senators and members of Congress.
It is not up to the Senate to determine the
constitutionality of things.
That's number one.
So a defense of Trump based on the alleged
unconstitutionality of an after the presidency,
impeachment is unfortunately invalid at its
base.
But it doesn't matter because they can make
whatever argument they want in the Senate
can accept or reject the argument.
But more importantly, Trump was not impeached
once.
He was no longer in office.
And even more importantly, you can impeach
a president after they are out of office.
Remember, the trial is happening after Trump
is out of office, but impeachment happens
in the House of Representatives.
And impeachment took place before January
20th when the House of Representatives impeach
Donald Trump for a second time.
Donald Trump was president of the United States
unless time now functions in some other way
that I don't understand.
But the Senate has previously had trials on
impeachment for officials who at that point
had already left office.
So what's more embarrassing in the end, that
Trump's own lawyers couldn't even correctly
spell the name of the country in which these
proceedings are taking place or the fact that
they're making an argument that is not only
wrong, but also pathetic and not up to the
jurisdiction of the Senate.
Take your pick.
It's like it's like a choose your own adventure.
And according to a report from Axios, Trump
has actually started to sort of privately
concede that a lot of the representation he's
had has been embarrassing to him.
It's it reflects a certain amount of self-awareness
that we've not really seen from Donald Trump
during his presidency.
But at this point, who even cares?
This is starting on Tuesday, will be covering
much of it.
And if this is a sign, if United States is
any indication of how Trump's legal team is
going to perform at next week's impeachment
trial, it's going to be quite a quite a scene
to watch and we'll be covering much of it.
When I read United States, it reminded me
of God bless the United States.
Many of you, I'm sure, remember that the Israelis
and Palestinians.
How does this even happen?
Like, doesn't spellcheck protect this, prevent
this from happening?
Like, I'm talking on a technical level, how
does it actually happen?
And one other thought I had as I was reading,
this is one of the big supposed selling points
about Donald Trump when he was running for
president, was that his best skill is hiring
people only the best people.
He's the he might not know about foreign policy.
He might not be an expert on whatever anything,
but he hires the best people.
And I have a hard time thinking of someone
who has demonstrated themselves to be worse
at hiring people than Donald Trump has been.
Trump's best, hilariously or sadly, Trump's
best employee might have been Christopher
Krebs, who said the election was secure.
And you really lost Mr. President and Trump
fired that guy.
The few people that by a mere chance seem
to be reasonable people that Trump has hired
or allowed to work for him seem to be the
first ones that Donald Trump fires.
And it is all a comedy of errors.
And we will be covering it.
We will be covering much of next week's impeachment
trial live on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook.
And I hope that you will join me.
We will also have continued coverage of the
United States on our Instagram page.
You can find us at David Pakman show on Instagram
and follow me while you're there at David
Pakman.
We'll take a quick break and be back with
Tom Hartman right after this.
The David Pakman
Show at David Pakman Dotcom.